[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - GORDON CHAMBERS,
"SONGWRITING MEDLEY"]
GORDON CHAMBERS: So I am
the common denominator
of all those songs.
But it's music lovers like you
that made them all number ones.
So right now, I'm
going to do a song.
On every album,
I cover something
that I've written in
my own special way.
Tonight, this one goes
out to a dedication
to two very important ladies
in my career, my first two
mentors, the late, great,
Phyllis Hyman, and a lady
that I wrote for,
who told me that it
was time for me to also
go solo as an artist.
Give it up for-- it's one
year since she went to glory.
Give it up for the
beautiful, incomparable,
and forever in our hearts,
Ms. Whitney Houston.
Last but not least,
for my beautiful,
the matriarch of
our family recently
gone home, Aunt
Barbara, Barbara Powell.
[MUSIC - GORDON CHAMBERS,
"NEVER FALL IN LOVE"]
[APPLAUSE]
GORDON CHAMBERS: Thank you.
So right now, I'm going
to bring to the stage
a good friend of mine.
We've been working together
for the last three years,
shows for the newest
album, "Sincere."
Everybody say "sincere."
AUDIENCE: Sincere.
GORDON CHAMBERS: And he
played at the first show.
You played at the first
"Sincere" album release,
right Ricky?
And I've been
admiring his talent.
He's an amazing guitar player.
I first saw him on the road with
Leela James and was blown away.
And I said, we're going
to get it together.
And it took a couple more
years, but we stayed in touch.
And I'm always appreciative that
he plays with me, because he's
a very hard-working man on
the road, who tours constantly
with Trey Songz.
So right now, as I said that
Whitney Houston was the one who
gave me that inspiration and
told me that it was my time
to not just write
but also to sing,
so then I began working
on the first solo album.
I'm going to do a cut
from the first solo album.
I'm going to do something
from the second solo album.
And I'm going to do a couple of
cuts from the third solo album,
if that's all right with y'all,
because I got three kids.
And I got to give them all love.
So are we plugged in?
Cool.
We good?
It's on you.
One, two, three, and--
Come on, I need some snaps.
We need some percussion
up in this piece.
Trey Songz was
actually in the studio
when we were recording
this very album.
Here we go.
[MUSIC - GORDON CHAMBERS,
"NEVER FALL IN LOVE"]
GORDON CHAMBERS: So that
was from album number one.
All three albums are
for sale tonight.
And I take credit cards, because
I have an iPhone and a Square.
So right now, I'm going
to bring to the stage
a young lady I
most recently met,
beautiful, beautiful songstress
living in Brooklyn as well,
another rising songbird.
Give it up for Amma Whatt as
she makes her way to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
GORDON CHAMBERS: This is
a song that I recorded
with a very good friend
of mine, Ms. Ledisi.
And it's called "To Love
Again," and it was a big hit.
So if you know it,
please sing along, y'all.
[MUSIC - GORDON CHAMBERS,
"TO LOVE AGAIN"]
[APPLAUSE]
GORDON CHAMBERS: Give it
up for Amma Whatt, y'all.
[APPLAUSE]
GORDON CHAMBERS: Give
it up for soul music.
[APPLAUSE]
GORDON CHAMBERS:
Give it up for Ricky.
And do not give it up
for this mic stand.
So now, we're going to do
some songs from the most
current album, "Sincere."
I shot this video of this
song in my house in Brooklyn.
Is Brooklyn in the house?
[APPLAUSE]
GORDON CHAMBERS: I shot
it right in my own house.
And it featured an
amazing acting performance
by a friend of ours, who's an
amazing singer, named Sy Smith.
So if you check out the
video for this song,
you'll see her acting
her behind off.
And you'll also see a woman
who surprised me and came out
tonight.
She's also in the video.
Ms. Ebony Joanne
is in the house.
Acting her behind
off in the video.
You got to love soul artists,
because as we work together,
and we're there for each
when we need each other,
aren't we, Ebony?
I think she's
working on her album.
So anyway, this song is a
song that actually Troy Taylor
wanted Trey Songz to record.
[SINGING] And Trey said, no,
no, no, no, no, and I said,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's called "I Can't Love
You (If You Don't Love You)."
Can I get a witness?
[MUSIC - GORDON CHAMBERS,
"I CAN'T LOVE YOU (IF YOU
DON'T LOVE YOU)"]
GORDON CHAMBERS: So this
is my last song tonight,
also from the "Sincere" album.
This is my favorite
song that I've ever
recorded as a solo
artist, my number one
iTunes-selling song
as a solo artist.
And I'm gonna have some
friends of mine come
and help me sing this, so
we can take it to church.
Do you mind if we take it
to church a little bit?
So welcome to the stage, my
friends, Duray, Dia, and Rasul.
[APPLAUSE]
GORDON CHAMBERS: Let me
slow it down a little bit.
[MUSIC - GORDON
CHAMBERS, "LEAD ME"]
GORDON CHAMBERS: We hope
you enjoyed it tonight.
Do you know why?
[MUSIC_-_GORDON_CHAMBERS]
[APPLAUSE]
GORDON CHAMBERS: Thank y'all.
My name is Gordon Chambers.
RYAN LOREN: All
right, everybody.
We're here to welcome
Gordon Chambers.
I'm so happy to have you here.
It's been a long time coming.
And Gordon, for those
of you who don't know,
is probably one of the
best writers in existence.
That's just one man's
opinion, but that's mine.
And so I'm going to talk to you
a little bit about your writing
process and all of that.
But first can you take
us back to the beginnings
and how you got started?
I know you've had
quite a background.
And just take us back.
GORDON CHAMBERS: It
began, it was all a dream,
I used to read
"Word Up" magazines.
Give love to Brooklyn
and Biggie Smalls, y'all.
Brooklyn in the house.
But I have lived in Brooklyn
for the last 15 years or so.
But I was born in the Bronx but
raised in a wonderful community
called Teaneck, New Jersey.
And I think some
Teaneck people are here.
And I'm grateful for
my town, because it
was a town where they were
just a wonderful group
of supportive parents, my
parents and music teachers.
And when I was in sixth
grade, I was writing songs.
I was given an assignment
to write a short story
about the book "Jonathan
Livingston Seagull."
And being the Libra creative
person that I am, I said,
instead of writing a short
story, I wrote a song.
And I showed the
teacher the song.
You said, well, that's
a really good song.
She said, why don't we teach
this to all the sixth graders?
And so she taught it to
all the sixth graders,
and it was performed
in a sixth grade
assembly for all the kids.
And then later on
in high school,
I continued writing songs.
And one of my best
friends in high school
was murdered by her boyfriend--
Donyale Morton, may she ever
rest in peace.
And after she passed, I
needed to do something
to process my feelings.
And I wrote a song
called "Always Be There."
And once again, I showed
it to some of the teachers
at the school.
And they were very
moved by the song.
And I shared it
with her parents.
And then one of the teachers
was a dance choreographer
at the school, Ms. Miller.
And she said, I'm going
to choreograph something
to this song so that
this will forever
live in the Teaneck
Terpsichoreans repertoire.
So she choreographed something.
And then other
students came forward.
We'll do a poem, and
then we'll do something.
So the birth of that song
created a whole evening
where 2,000 people
came to just give
creative remembrances
of Donyale.
So I really felt like
God had chosen me
as a child to provide
songs that could inspire
and that could heal.
And so after that,
I went to college,
I went to Brown University,
kept on writing.
Then I took a job at
"Essence" magazine
and became the entertainment
editor of "Essence."
And I served in that
position for seven years.
And that was a great
networking place.
And so while I was
there hanging out,
I met a wonderful lady, Phyllis
Hyman, may she rest in peace.
And she took me under her wing,
and I also met Queen Latifah.
And so Queen Latifah
and Phyllis Hyman
were the first two superstars,
who not only became friends
but mentors and had me write
on some of their albums.
And then I met other
people, like producers
Barry Eastman,
Dave Hall, and then
started writing some
of the songs that
became number one hits and
sold millions of records.
God is good.
So some of those songs
include, Anita Baker's
"I Apologize," Brownstone's
"If You Love Me, Say It,"
the theme from "Set It
Off," "Missing You,"
by Brandy, Tamia, Gladys
Knight, and Chaka Khan,
as well as cuts for Whitney
Houston, Tamia, Brandy, Gladys
Knight, Marc Anthony, Patti
Labelle, Chaka Khan Chaka
Khan, and 75 recording artists.
Thank you, Lord.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN LOREN: I am
curious about this.
And I ask other artists,
too, but can you
talk about the process you use
to write and how it happens?
Is it different every time?
Do you create conditions
that make it happen?
Or what would you do?
GORDON CHAMBERS: I have a
different writing process.
It just depends what it is.
Some songs of mine I
write at the piano,
and they tend to
be more ballads.
But a lot of times,
collaborations
are about opposites attracting.
So a lot of my songs
have been written
with producers that were
quote unquote "beat guys."
But the producers I got
a chance to work with
were more than just beat people.
Stevie J. And Dave
Hall, these were
guys who had real fabulous
musicianship on top
of their beats.
But they had hard beats.
They knew how to knock
their heads in the studio.
My glasses are falling off.
It was like, I was
a man who would
come in with the
melody on top, and they
would have the beat knocking.
And that's how you had that
great opposites attract
of music.
So sometimes it was a situation
of being given a great track.
"If You Love Me" was a track
that Dave Hall presented me.
And he gave it to me on a CD.
And one morning-- I'm
Jamaican, so Jamaicans
are notoriously late.
I was on time today, though.
Jamaicans are notoriously late.
So one day, I was
on my way, late
to my job at "Essence"
magazine, I swear to God.
It just started to pour rain
as I was thinking about what
lie I could call Susan
Taylor with and tell her
I was going to be late, because
I had every lie in the book--
the cat, the grandmother died,
the this, the that, blah, blah.
What lie can I tell?
I swear, God was like,
don't tell any more lies,
because the rain
started pouring down.
I popped Dave Hall's track
into the CD player of my car,
and all I heard
were those chords.
And the first line of "If
You Love Me" came to me.
"I don't want to rain on this
parade," inspired by the rain
as I was late to work.
Songs can come anywhere.
I've literally had songs hit me.
One day, I was
getting a haircut.
I was in the barber shop.
And this idea came to me.
And the barber
scratched my head,
because I was like, I
need a pen, I need a pen.
And he's like, yo,
I'm about to cut you.
And he really did cut me
with the barber thing.
But that was when the words to
a song that I wrote for Brandy
called "One Voice," they
came to me immediately.
So I think being a songwriter
is about being open,
having something to say.
It takes being a
sensitive person.
You have to be in touch
with your emotions.
You can't be the alpha male
to be a great songwriter.
You really have to be
the sensitive male.
You have to know what you feel
and be able to articulate it,
because the women audience,
they get it right away.
But it's interesting, since I've
become a performer, not just
a songwriter, I have found
that my songs now, especially
the songs on my solo
albums, are speaking
to the men very poignantly.
A lot of the men have told
me that buy my records
and go to my concerts,
they said, thank you
for saying for me what I didn't
have the emotional sensitivity
and that kind of courage to say.
So it's about being open.
RYAN LOREN: Thanks very much.
So can you talk
about, obviously,
you're not just a writer.
You're also a performer,
singer, artist.
So what was the
critical point where
you decided, all right,
I'm going to do this?
GORDON CHAMBERS: It had been
in my mind for a long time.
Because I was in the
studio all the time
writing songs for
other artists, people
don't realize that I sang
all of those songs first.
I did the demos
for "I Apologize."
I did the demo
for "Missing You."
I did the demo for
"If You Love Me."
So the artist who
record the songs
were always listening
to my voice.
I would lay the lead vocals
and the background vocals.
I was always in the
studios recording.
And I knew how to record.
And then in my years
as entertainment editor
at "Essence," I was going
to all the concerts.
I've seen everyone in concert.
And I was going backstage, I was
hanging out with the artists,
interviewing the artists.
So I was having the
best artist development
that one could ever have,
because I was seeing it
on the side of a journalist.
So I was really learning
about the business.
But then there was the fear.
I was like, afraid to step
from one side to the other.
And it was something I wanted to
do, but I was afraid to do it.
And then sometimes you
just have to be open
and ask people for help.
What happened was
I started to-- not
get afraid of making
the music but afraid
of asking the very people
around me to help me,
because I knew that I didn't
have tons and tons of money.
But I want to make
a quality project.
But the day that changed my
life was, I was in the studio,
producing the late and
great Whitney Houston.
And I was producing
a song for her.
And I told her that I wanted
her to hit a certain note.
And I kept telling her to
hit it higher and higher.
And then she looked
me in the face,
and she said, "I think
you want to do what I do.
And if that's what
you want to do,
then that's what
you need to do."
And I looked at her,
like, what did she say?
She was really in my face, too.
And she's from Newark, so
what she gets in your face,
it's kind of.
So the Newark came on,
the Brooklyn stepped back.
And I said, well,
what do you mean?
She said, I think
you want to sing.
If that's what you
want to do, then that's
what you should be doing.
And it was like one those
times when an angel speaks Word
into your life, and you feel it.
And it penetrates your heart.
So shortly after that, I went
to church the Sunday after that,
and my minister Pastor Trouffant
at Emmanuel Baptist Church
in Brooklyn gave a sermon
about how not to wait,
that now is your time,
whatever you want to do.
And he talked about
how Jesus died at 36.
And many of the miracles
that you read about
were done in the last
three years of his life.
So he said, don't
wait for your time
if there's something
you want to do.
And so after Whitney
preached to me in the studio
and then Pastor Trouffant
preached to me, then I said,
it's time.
The universe is telling me.
And I called all my
friends in the business.
And I said, I think I'm
ready to make a solo record.
And everyone said yes.
My producer Troy Taylor
said, come on through.
We're going to do
it in my basement.
And we went to his basement, my
friend's publicist, Gwendolyn
Quinn.
These are people I had all
worked with at "Essence,"
but I was afraid to ask them
to help me on my own stuff.
Gwendolyn Quinn said,
I'll do your PR.
Everyone I reached
out to said, we
have been waiting
for this moment.
And they all helped me,
started booking shows,
booked the very first
show at Joe's Pub.
I swear, I thought 10
people were going to come.
They had to turn
200 people away.
Then the night of
the album release,
we had the album release
around the corner at BB
King's-- packed, packed,
almost a sold out show.
It's just from the jump,
it's as if the world
had been waiting for me
to step into my greatness.
And sometimes
that's what you have
to do is, just listen to
what the universe is trying
to tell you and don't be
afraid to step into it.
RYAN LOREN: Thanks a lot.
Let's give it up for that.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN LOREN: Last question--
so about the music, talk to us
about what the last
album meant to you.
That was your third
album, "Sincere,"
and then what's next?
GORDON CHAMBERS: Every album
gets more and more personal.
The first album was called
"Introducing Gordon Chambers,"
which featured collaborations
with friends-- Roy
Hargrove, Mike Phillips.
Carl Thomas is on that album.
So the first album had a
slightly jazzy feeling to it.
"Love Stories" featured
a duet with Ledisi,
"To Love Again,"
which became a big hit
record on a lot
of radio stations.
Then the third album, "Sincere,"
which is the most recent album,
I just wanted to make
an album that I felt
was very, very personal.
And I want to make
an album this time
from the perspective of
being a live performer.
The first two albums were
more from the perspective
of a songwriter that's
writing and also sings.
This one was started from the
perspective of a performer,
and I wanted to give people
lyrically a backstage, up close
and personal emotional
look at what my life is.
I wanted to be
more as vulnerable
as I could be with the lyrics.
That's why the first
song on the album
is called "I'm In
The Band," because it
was written from
that perspective.
I'm in the process of
making another album called
"Conversations With God."
And it's going to be
an inspirational album.
It's going to have a
spiritual tonality,
but I'm also talking
about relationships,
I'm talking about life.
And I'm just getting
more and more
vulnerable with each album.
I feel that the
R&B male tradition
has been taken over
by the sexuality.
And I want to provide
more of the sensitivity
and the sensuality into
the lyrical landscape.
RYAN LOREN: Amen to that.
Thanks for being here.
Everybody, I've learned a
lot from Gordon in my life.
We've known each
other a few years.
You're a role model
to many people.
GORDON CHAMBERS: Thank you.
RYAN LOREN: Thanks so
much for being here.
GORDON CHAMBERS: Thank you
for doing this for us here.
Thank you.
RYAN LOREN: Of course.
GORDON CHAMBERS:
See y'all later.
[APPLAUSE]